more than anything in my experience hope
is what beats in the heart of all people
particularly in the heart of the Irish
hope
every action is about hope it can make
things better
and hope to build both our Nations has
been passed down generation to
Generation by our families
and let's hope that continues this day
nearly 45 years ago as some of you may
remember none of you women are old
enough to know but some of you men may
be 45 years ago Pope John Paul spoke
down the road
quoting St Patrick and the pope said and
I quote
I have kept the faith and has been the
ambition of the Irish Downs to the
centuries to have kept the faith
I think that's who we are we keep the
faith I'm not not talking about religion
per se I'm talking about Keeping the
Faith
the faith in who we are what we believe
what our values are
so my message here today is quite simple
we have to continue to keep the faith
every time I walk out this is not a joke
walk out of my grandpa Finning his house
up in Scranton Pennsylvania he'd yelled
Joey keep the faith and then my either
my uncle and my grandmother would yell
no joy spread it spread it but all
together we have to keep working toward
the future that's of Greater dignity and
as we Face darkness and there's Darkness
we have to face